Hello, this is Sonny calling from a very rainy Houston,
Texas radio lab is supported by dash digital cash dash allows you to send any
amount of money using a highly secure peer to peer network.
Skip the bank entirely and control your money your way.
Dash is digital cash. For more information,
visit [inaudible] dot org forward slash radio labs
the I'm Jad and I'm Robert and this is radio lab. Today on our program,
the topic is liar, all kinds of liars and now it's time for the liar.
We haven't yet mentioned a layer which might actually be one very familiar to
you. Jad this is the, uh, the self deceiver. Hey,
would you know that you might get somebody, somebody who lies a not to others,
but actually lies to oneself if you get my drift? Thanks. Which thanks a lot.
Anyhow. What does that even mean to lie to oneself? How would you,
that's tricky. Let me give you a classic example.
Let's say that you are madly in love with somebody who just conjure up whoever
you really, you know, I don't know who. Okay, so now you're in love with her.
And strange things start to happen. Oh,
you were at home. The phone rings, you pick it up, hello,
and the person on the other end of the line is breathing and then hangs up next.
She's suddenly staying late at the office many nights a week. Didn't use it.
She said, honey, I've got to work late tonight. Again, don't wait up.
Then your friends tell you that they see this woman who's this guy in the
company of a man. You have a brother maybe repeatedly, dude, c'mon. Okay.
In short, all the signs are there and yet, despite the evidence,
you Jed continue to believe, and I mean you truly,
truly believe that the woman is being faithful. Well,
maybe in this little scenario that you've created for me,
I'm just a stupid or clueless. No,
I'm not going to take that away from you. I'm not. But in this case though,
for the sake of argument, let's say you're not clear, okay?
Let us say you believe both these things in some different compartments in your
head. You believe that she is faithful at the very same time. You know?
You know what's really going on here? What's up deception really is,
is that you have two contradictory beliefs and you hold them at the same time
and you allow one of them into consciousness and that you have a motivation for
allowing one of them into consciousness. That's Joanna steric.
She's a psychologist and we're going to hear more from her later. Right?
So how does that work then? What, what you just said,
beg to have two contradictory thoughts in your brain at the same time and get
your own letting in one. Well, there's an experiment on this subject.
Kind of an interesting one.
And so what other experiment introduced you to the two guys who did it?
It's for, okay. Uh, uh, Harold [inaudible] professor in the
Departments of Psychiatry and Radiology at Columbia University. Okay.
My name is Ruben Gore. I'm a neuropsychologist by training.
Harold Sackheim and Reuben Glare are friends.
They met back in 1974 or 73 and make that 73 one was a grad student.
That would be Harold moment as a professor. That's Gore.
And we started talking and make a long story short,
we did a couple of experiments
and one of them we played clips of one's own voice and the voices of other
people. And here's the experiment. You the subject are sitting in a room, okay,
all right. And we're going to give you a big red button and you can press it.
Press the button yet. No sorry. And out of the speakers in this room,
you're going to hear 10 different voices.
And everybody was saying the same thing. The words were to say come here,
come here, come here, come here, come here, come here.
And one of the voices in this group, one of the many is huge ad.
You saying come here. That was you.
When you hear yourself saying com, press the button. Press a button.
Me Or not me. When you, when you hear your own voice. So one of these in mind.
Yup, come here. Come here. Come here. Come here. Come here. Come here. No here,
come here. Come here. Come here. Come here. Come here.
Come here. Come think. Oh here, come here. Come here. Come here. Come here.
Not me here. Come now. If you listen very closely, it's going to come three me,
I'm shooting. I come here, not me, not me. Now he missed it. Right.
It's hard. You're right. And the people in Harold study,
many of them didn't do too well either because they had some trouble recognizing
their own voice. Uh, all right, bring it home. Robert, what's the point of this?
But here's what I didn't tell you. When they did this experiment in real life,
the real subjects in addition to having a little pusher button thing that we
gave you. Yeah.
They also had diodes all over their body measuring recorded their physio and
CRISPR aeration inspecting heart rate, stuff like that. Blood pressure.
And what they found is that when a person failed to recognize his or her voice,
nevertheless their bodies, the sweat heart blows so often the body's going,
their body seemed to notice their voices even though their conscious minds miss
the voices, the body knew. The conscious mind didn't.
Two thoughts in the same person. Come on now. I mean I'll give it to you.
That's kind of interesting. But that's it. That is not the same thing as lying.
While we're just starting here, we're just, this is now at least grant me this.
You can have two different experiences simultaneous. Okay.
I granted that you're on our way. We're on our way. Okay. Step two,
Harold and Ruben decide to leave the laboratory and go to a bar. Yeah,
I believe it was smokey Joe's just to sort of talk things over and kick back and
to deal with your very question like,
so let's really get to the core of what lying to yourself is about, et cetera.
So they're in the bar and they're getting kind of drunk.
We were probably pretty, John and Rubin proposes,
we need to come up with some way to get test subjects to have one thought and
instantly have a contradictory thought.
Maybe we could do that with embarrassment.
Maybe we could embarrass them into having two thoughts at the same time.
And yes, and at some point I said, let's ask people questions, questions,
so threatening,
so uncomfortable that you don't want to tell the truth about the quick way.
What questions would those be? Well, I mean we had to get down and dirty.
They got drunker and drunker and drunker and they came up with a whole bunch of
them writing them down right there in the bar on the Napkin. We were curious.
So we took their questions off the napkins so to speak,
and we brought them out onto the street.
Can I ask you some questions while you're waiting? Yeah, sure.
So here's what have you ever doubted your sexual adequacy? Oh No. And Yeah.
Another. Have you ever enjoyed your bowel movements? Enjoyed my bowel.
I think most normal people do. No. Here's another,
have you ever thought to committing suicide and it was to get back at somebody?
Yes. No, and another. Okay.
Have you ever wanted to rape feeling great for somebody? Come again? No. No.
Absolutely not. Oh No. Well, yeah. Have I had,
what kind of question is that? If you answered no to any of those questions,
they would say that you're lying to yourself.
So they are assuming then that everybody enjoys their bowel movements secretly.
Everyone secretly has raped what they are assuming. Yes.
It was a supposition that these things are universal truths,
but it was a supposition that seemed to work
because that night at the bar, Harold and Rubin stumbled across something.
It turns out that how you answer those questions predict some very surprising
things about the kind of person you are.
How about the course of your whole life? First of all,
remember that previous study we talked about with the voices,
it just so happens that the people who were very bad at the voice test failed
the voice test.
They were the very same people who did very badly on the embarrassing
questionnaire test. They didn't,
when we admit to stuff, have you ever wanted to rape or be raped by somebody?
Uh, now not at all, Huh? However,
when other scientists got ahold of Harold and Ruben's questionnaire and they
used it a lot in lots of situations,
can give it to thousands and thousands of people.
They dug deeper into the question of of what are these people who have trouble
with truthiness? What happens to them in life? And,
and it turns out that they do a whole lot better in all kinds of areas.
Better, better, better, you know, all kinds of things. Like what?
A whole lot of stuff like coming now say, by the way, these people are liars.
I am not quite ready to say that,
but let's just call them liars and can you please tell me what the hell you're
talking about? What, what sorts of things did they do better at? Well,
just to start, let me introduce you to someone. Okay.
My name is Joanna steric and I'm a psychologist,
psychologist and athlete. I was actually a swimmer.
I was a competitive swimmer at Colgate university and I think one of the
questions that I was really interested in is how can you have two people who
have the same physiological capacity and then one person over and over again
would consistently win or outperform the other?
Joanna had heard about Harold and Ruben's questionnaire,
so she and her research partner, Carolyn Keating,
decided to give the embarrassing question questionnaire to the swim team. Yes.
Just to see what they'd find.
So we gave them that questionnaire at the beginning of the season and then they
trained trying to qualify for the eastern Athletic Conference Championship.
That's the big race of the end of the year. It's, it's a very objective measure.
You either swim fast enough during the season to qualify or you don't.
And when at the end of the season, Joanna and her research partner,
Caroline looked at which swimmers did the best, which ones qualify.
We did find a bizarre relationship. This swimmers who said the one,
the liars who said no to all these questions.
Did you enjoy your bowel movements? No.
Have you ever thought about killing yourself? No.
Have you ever thought about raping summit? No.
Consistently they were the winners.
The fastest and most successful swimmers.
What are the ones who on the questionnaire according to Harold and Ruben,
lied to themselves? Yes.
I do think a little bit of deception is not necessarily a bad thing.
[inaudible]
it might even be a crucial thing. And just for example,
I want you to listen to these Olympic track athletes.
We got these interview clips from the sound artist, Ben Ruben.
I listened to how these athletes describe the process of getting ready to race.
We believe we are investible is if we go in there with any other thought death,
no chance of US accomplishing our goal.
Well of course I always win in my thoughts.
I have the ability to catch this person. It's going to happen.
Take your head off, leave your head at home. Leave your brain at home.
Today when I stepped on the runway, I just relaxed myself.
[inaudible]
you are the best and I go and more than sports,
denying certain facts about the real world around you according to any number of
new studies producers,
people who turns out are better at business and better at working with teams and
now here's the real kicker. They turn out to be happier.
[inaudible] the question, you're served a couple of [inaudible].
The purpose is one of the things that had taught us is that people who were
happiest are the ones who are lying to themselves more
people who are the most realistic that actually see the world exactly as it is,
tend to be slightly more depressed than others. Time and time again.
Researchers have found that depressed people lie
less. They see all the pain in the world,
how horrible people are with each other,
and they tell you everything about themselves, what their weaknesses are,
terrible things they've done to other people. And the problem is they're right
[inaudible]
and so maybe it's the way we help people to help them be wrong.
It might just be that hiding ideas that we know to be true.
Hiding those ideas from ourselves is what we need to get by.
We're so vulnerable to being here and we're given the capacity to the store as a
gift.
No.
Well, that's it for us.
If you want any more information on anything you've heard this hour,
check our website, Radio lam.org I'm Robert Krulwich chat up on Ron,
who this is radio lab. Thanks for listening.